(host)
A snowstorm is one
weather phenomenon
you don't want to
be surprised by.
The same can be said
of the Yuki Onna,
one of Japan's harshest
winter monsters.
This icy snow maiden might
steal your heart or your life.
She's beautiful and dangerous.
The incarnation
of winter storms.
In some regions of Japan,
just catching a
glimpse of this figure
will cause your soul
to leave your body.
Other places give her
the trait of motherhood.
She will ask you
to hold her baby
or may appear accompanied
by snow children.
And in some region stories,
she's a vengeful spirit,
actively seeking out
those who wronged her
when she was alive.
[dramatic music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
Many legends of the Yuki Onna
originate in the Tohoku region.
Located in the mountainous
northeastern part
of the country known as
one of the coldest regions
of the island,
the area sees more snowfall
than any other region in Japan.
The Yuki Onna is
identified by the blizzards
she travels with as beautiful
and pale as the falling snow.
She may have black
or white hair,
but it is always very long.
Her thin tall body
can appear naked,
but more often it is wrapped
in a blindingly white kimono.
Yuki Onna looks like a woman.
So, many mistake
her for a ghost,
but she isn't the
spirit of a dead person.
(Emily)
That's Hiroko Yoda,
author of the yokai book,
"Yokai Attack: The Japanese
Monster Survival Guide."
(Hiroko)
She is a yokai,
a living personification
of cold and winter.
[ominous music]
But I don't consider
Yuki Onna a monster.
I see her as
an avatar of nature.
The fact she's wearing a thin
kimono in such condition.
It's strange, but the
white color, it's odd too.
Of course, it's
symbolizes frost and snow.
[Yuki Onna speaking Japanese]
But traditionally, white
kimono are also used
as a burial dress for the dead.
It would be very
scary to see a woman
dressed in a light white
kimono in a blizzard.
(Emily)
She can shapeshift
into mist or falling snow.
Making her invisible
against the blizzard
she appears alongside.
The better to sneak up
on her victims.
(Hiroko)
Yuki Onna's story
is a classic example.
She tells us to never
underestimate
the power of nature
and to be extra cautious
when going out in the winter,
especially into the wilderness.
(Emily)
The Yuki Onna is a kind of
winter succubus-type yokai.
Stories tell of her
acts of seduction.
Encounters that always
end with her draining
the life force of the men
she has relations with.
More notoriously, however,
victims die of the cold
either through exposure
to the elements
or the woman's icy breath.
The snow woman first appears
in a collection of poetry
written in the 15th century
by Sogi, a zen monk.
He describes the Yuki Onna
he encountered
as tall and beautiful with
very pale skin and white hair.
His experience is
accompanied by another tale
that would become one
of the most enduring
versions of the Yuki Onna.
The story of the woodcutter.
Legend has it that while
cutting down trees,
Minokichi and
his mentor Mosaku
were caught in
a horrible blizzard.
Unable to cross
the river to return home,
they seek shelter
in a boatman's hut.
Later that night, Minokichi
wakes up freezing.
Noticing the door
to the hut is open,
he turns to
his mentor and sees
a stunningly beautiful
woman standing over him.
She has extraordinarily
pale skin
and is wearing
a snow white kimono.
She freezes the mentor
with her icy breath
then turns her piercing
gaze to Minokichi,
but is immediately taken
by the man's own beauty.
He was unusually handsome.
She agrees to let him
live on the condition
that he tells no
one what happened.
She then walks
out of the shelter
disappearing into the blizzard.
A year later, Minokichi
meets a very beautiful woman
who coincidentally also
has very pale skin.
The two marry and
have 10 children.
Clearly, they were
into each other.
But strangely, she never seems
to age remaining as young
and beautiful as she was
on their wedding day.
All was well until
one fateful night.
Seeing his wife dressed
all in white Minokichi
absentmindedly
comments that she looks
just like the snow woman he
encountered so many years ago.
To his surprise and horror,
his wife reveals
she herself is the Yuki Onna.
The wife turn on him,
furious.
She screamed, "It was me
who spared you that day.
I should kill you for
breaking your promise."
(Emily)
She abandons him,
turning into a white mist
and floating out of a window,
never to be seen again.
This particular
Yuki Onna legend
is the most popular today
largely because of Patrick
Hearn's 1904 translation
of the story in
his book "Kwaidan."
This Irish Greek
author published
under a Japanese pen name
and claimed to have
recorded the story
from a local of the
Musashino district.
However, scholars are
careful to point out
that the story is unlikely
a direct translation.
Romance between the Yuki Onna
and the young lumberjack
is significantly more
detailed in his telling
than in other variations.
According to his version,
the Yuki Onna
when disguised as a human
woman is named O-Yuki.
Her name literally
translates to snow,
which you think would've been
a clue for the woodcutter.
But I digress.
The marriage element is common
in other Japanese folk tales.
As is the husband
breaking a promise
to his supernatural wife.
Other traditions across the
globe also use this trope
so it's an interesting
thread to explore.
These supernatural
unions seem to reflect
an idealistic fantasy.
The preternatural wife is
always incredibly attractive
as defined by the ideal beauty
standards of that community.
And Yuki Onna stories,
for instance,
female beauty is
defined by pale skin,
long hair, and thinness.
All characteristics
still held in high regard
by popular culture
in Japan today.
But Hiroko
has another opinion.
I don't think portrayal
of Yuki Onna's beauty
is about women at all.
Instead, she's a personification
of the beauty of winter.
She's like a
metaphor reminding us
that the cold month
are beautiful,
but it can also be deadly.
(Emily)
Another well-known
tale of the Yuki Onna
that diverges from the
supernatural marriage trope
appears in a 1705 play titled
"The Five Battledores
of the Yuki Onna."
Penned by Chikamatsu
Monzaemon, a noted kabuki
and puppet theater playwright.
He wrote both historical
and domestic dramas.
In other words, he wrote
about both legendary deeds
and heroic figures as well
as everyday domestic life.
"The Five Battledores
of the Yuki Onna"
falls somewhere in
between both categories.
His version removes
the relationship
between yokai and man in favor
of a vengeful ghost story.
The drama centers on a man
planning on assassinating
a shogun in his home during
the New Year holiday.
In order to do so,
he must get
the shogun's devoted
maid out of the house.
So, he tells her that her boss
is planning to send an army to
fight the Lord of her lover.
He instructs her to warn
the others in the household
ensuring the woman
that his brother
is waiting outside
the garden gate
to help her leave the property.
In truth, this is a lie.
No one waits for her outside
the still locked gates
and the trapped maid
freezes to death
inside the
snow-covered courtyard,
but she does not
perish entirely.
Upon her death, she
transforms into a snow woman.
Her blue kimono replaced
with a white one.
Then she seeks revenge
against the man
who sent her on
the false errand.
While the dangers of
being stuck outside
on a snowy evening
are self-explanatory,
this Yuki Onna tale also
warns of the consequences
of trying to change
the social order
by usurping the leader
of the community,
in this case, the military.
After all,
the would-be assassin
is punished by the
vengeful snow woman.
But the fact that the maid
becomes the monster herself
also suggests that
all lives are valuable.
Even if a person
is not perceived
as a high-ranking
member of society,
their lives are
no less important.
While the dangers of frostbite
and hypothermia are universal
the minor changes in the
yokai's appearance and actions
reflect regional
cultural expectations
and potentially
real life events.
(Hiroko)
She's popular character
in folk tales
so they are many variations,
but generally speaking, her
attributes don't change much.
She's a beautiful
woman in a white kimono
in the depth of winter.
She reminds us of that,
but her story also tells us
never to make promises
we cannot keep.
(Emily)
So there you have it,
and I mean, hey,
once you inspired a Pokemon
it's pretty hard to ignore
the pop culture relevance.
What was once a metaphor
for the dangers of winter,
and a warning against
false assurances of trust
has become a beloved but
less terrifying character.
Expanding her reach,
but also her variation.
What was once a metaphor
for the dangers of winter
and a warning against false
insurances of trust...
Assurances not insurances.
Holy moley.
Assurances of--
(director)
Assurances.
"Falsh ashurances."
False assurances of trust.